was du gemacht hast du davon
und ja am mittag viel spaß ja
jo leute und herzlich willkommen zu dem
körper schlangen fieberkurven fieber
ich bin gelb sowie tag ist lila oder
pink und denis hughes ist rot die beiden
sind eine beschreibung und ja leute wie
immer geht ich beantworte alle
kommentare also scheint fleißig in die
kommentare
dennis du hund zu tun was er mir direkt
den weg abschneiden nicht aufgepasst wie
konnte das passieren
jetzt gegenüber alte
ja ja ja ja ja ja ich hab's euch team
gegen ausrichter machen schreibt ob die
kommentar in die kommentare
das ist ja geschafft einfach noch
gefragt wie kann er das auch schaffen
viel spaß
ja nicht klar bin ich langsam bin ich
dumm bin ich denn dumm bin ich denn doma
frustriert darüber dass langsam gemacht
hat nein
genau wie bei dem video von lukas geht
es jetzt keine gute position aufgeben
ich boxe ich heute krank
ja ich habe es ist nicht zu fassen
ich muss echt mal auf platz acht
ich habe gar nicht du blickt wie ich bin
alt
genau da hat sich so eine lücke gibt ja
viel spaß heute viel spaß und soja oder
best wer als erstes drei gewinnt besten
ich würde sagen mal gucken wie lange wir
zwischen der aufnahme seien sechs
minuten lagen wir noch einen run teil
noch alles dran kurzen card oder machen
wir weiter leute ihr seid die war ihr
seid dabei wie es direkt weiter gehen
ist das geil ist das geil und jetzt
werde ich mal ein bisschen auftreten ihr
wisst ihr bescheid so schlank
diese siegelung besiegelt meine
besiegelung bewegung komme ich schon
durch verstand ich du warst ja eine
richtige action gleichauf
jetzt ist alles anders
was sozial
aufpassen muss man aufpassen wo ich mit
meinem leben und ich habe auch gewonnen
oder bist du bist ein arschloch dennis
gestorben
schaut einfach mal genau hin weil dieser
stelle gerade im sport immer dahin
zurück abschneiden so kann ich auf den
weg abschneiden und ich gewinnt dieser
runde
ja ja ja ja also die schildkröte für die
gegner ist nicht immer schlechter ohne
witz
ja und ich gewinne
das war so dumm
ich hab mal könnte man hätte in kürzeren
wendekreis und man langsamer ist aber
hat man einfach nicht yalla sieht kommt
zum 2
ich hätte so locker sie mal richtig fett
punkte holen können
jetzt muss ich mich wirklich mal wieder
konzentrieren sowie kleider pjsc nicht
und dann ist was willst du denn es wird
ja ja ja ja ja ja leute ich bin es der
sg und ich war ich kaputt
es muss ja wirklich gewinner sondern
sage ja mache ich erstmal kaputter unten
und ich dann ist hier oben raus viel
spaß und dan ist zuletzt den hiergegen
ja ja ja nein aber glück gehabt
ok also jetzt geht's um die wurst da hab
ich grad risiko gespielt er
denn es heißt du bist ich bitte sie
bitte alles ja ja ja ja es gibt 21
was was was warum habe ich gewonnen was
nike nein man muss nur zwei punkten
abstand gewinnen
bis 22 aber aber n24 jetzt ein alter 24
muss als erster raus fliegen
jaja leute ich wünsche euch viel spaß
mit speed let's go uhren so nein du
arschloch hat es einfach doch diese
richtung umkehren eingesammelt oh mein
gott alter was für ein finale das wird
so eine ewig lange folge hier nicht so
ne habe ich dran denn ist du bist ein
idiot du bist so ein idiot du kannst
doch eh nichts mehr reißen
du kannst nichts mehr reißen ja ja ja ja
ja ja alter wenn ich jetzt wenn denn ist
das erste runde gewonnen
und dann nimmst du behindert als gewand
ja und ja und ja und ja ach scheiße man
kriegt man kriegt die punkterunde was
für ein krasses finale
jetzt will ich jetzt hier richtig
richtiges herzschlagfinale richtig was
meinst du bist ein mongole denn ist doch
einfach ab alter noch einfacher wechseln
denkst du
tsg nein nein nein nein
er gewinnt einfach gar nichts okay das
war eine mega krasse runde also leute
ich würde sagen hat sich gefallen hat
daumen nach oben bei der bisher in gang
geblieben seid weil er mehr von solchen
action runden volt daumen nach oben
lässt und hatte die kommentare was ihr
dazu denkt ihr wisst wie immer wieder
immer antwort ja alle kommentare
beantworten
und ja in diesen sinne macht dort haut
rein und y